A wallet that looks like a matchbook and edible
spray paint.
It's episode 21 of LÜT.
The mince that come in this spam tin actually
taste like cinnamon, but this lip balm tastes
like Lucky Charms.
Question.
What's warmer than a sweater and a mug of
hot chocolate?
Answer: a mug wearing a sweater.
Keep your hands equally warm with predator
and pray mittens.
One hand's a cat, the other's a dog.
One's a frog, one's fly.
One's an owl and other is a mouse.
Or, use Tatchies.
They let you get touchy with your touchscreen
without removing your gloves.
Of course, all of these gloves will cover
up your awesome ring with the stone set upside
down, making it a "Killer Ring."
Or this ring with a hidden diamond.
Generate also has synthetic leather bags that
look like envelopes, wing rings and shirts
with special stripes you can wipe your glasses
with.
But let's talk about moulds that make your
cookies into moustaches.
Or, these cupcake pillows.
A giant ice cream sandwich pillow is also
fun and barbed wire toilet paper is mainly
just scary.
Kisses are better, but hey, this bath towel
makes it look like you're wearing a kilt.
So let's talk high fashion and cover funny hats.
Stupid.com also offers this tiny peace sign
hat for your little dog, and of course a hat
that looks like underwear.
Does this guy even know that his hat is funny?
I also like their hands waving USA flags hat.
Keep things patriotic with these flag pants.
Betabrand also carries these dress pants that
are actually sweatpants.
Now, if you've mainly made history wearing
shirts, use Urban Outfitters' t-shirt frames
to preserve those memories.
Or design your own on this t-shirt design
notepad.
Also a good option - this note-pad.
Then toast your good taste with some bacon-flavored
soda, perfect for washing down a giant burrito.
Just kidding.
It's a protective wrap for valuable camera
lenses.
Improve your view with Generate's skyline
blinds and improve your bathroom with this
real aquarium sink - a perfect companion to
the iPoop toilet.
Your iPhone will be fine if you drop it in,
because you've waterproofed it with Liquipel.
Or, you're busy looking like an executive
with the iPhone handset converter.
Now these puzzles are shaped like donuts,
pizza or coffee, but the world record holding
largest puzzle can be yours.
It has more than 32,000 pieces and weighs
over 37 pounds.
For a more dare devilish challenge, play Russian
Roulette with water balloons.
You never when the gun will pierce the balloon.
But for a sweeter challenge, Bite The Bullet
gives you a dozen delicious chocolates shaped
like bullets, except one contains a hidden
dangerously hot pepper.
Good luck.
If your sweet tooth also likes blink, pick
up some twinkles.
Dental jewellery made with a special adhesive
that only lets go when you want to remove
it.
Clean the rest of your teeth with some floss
you pulled out of a dog's butt and clean your
body with tetromino shaped soap, behind your
Facebook-styled shower curtain.
Then, decorate your hair with these comic-inspired
headbands and show it all off in front of
the paparazzi that you hired.
For an hour, at $100 a photographer, this
company will send paparazzi to harass you
and make you look famous no matter who you are.
If you get a boo-boo during the whole process,
be sure you're caught wearing a brandage.
Question.
Can you identify which characters these eyes
belong to?
Well, they're sonic.
You can play on the site or you can grab the
picture as an art print.
Speaking of posters, here's a map of the world
made with what makes it go round.
Moustaches.
And here's a fictional map made out of places
made famous in songs.
Just take the "Highway to Hell" after "Heartbreak
Hotel" and picnic in "Itchycoo Park."
This artist on Etsy will make an incredible
custom stamp that actually looks just like you.
Now, separate salt and pepper shakers are
fine, but Fred makes this Switch - pick what
you want and shake.
Your earbuds can be superheroes and your ears
can also delight in wearing some handmade
Calvin and Hobbes earrings.
If Hobbes means something more philosophical
to you, pick up a Hobbes mug.
Now, how about a free thing?
Try Night Soil.
This is the word for human poop that you steal
from outhouses and the trains and cesspools
at night in order to use us as free fertiliser
on your crops.
It's a bad idea.
Don't do it.
Compose that stuff first, come on.
But seriously, here are some great iPhone
backgrounds that you can get for free from
a great LÜT site.
A Rhombicuboctahedron has 26 faces, which
is also the number of years old I'm turning
today.
That's right.
It's my birthday and you're all invited to
the party.
Consider the comment section the party...
And as always,
thanks for watching.